양자 정보와 계산 이해하기에 다시 오신 걸 환영해요. 저는 John Wattrus이고요, IBM Quantum의 교육
기술 총괄 디렉터예요. 이번이 이 시리즈의 11번째 강의이고, 세 번째 단원의 세 번째 강의인데요,
세 번째 단원은 양자 정보의 일반적인 공식화에 대한 내용이에요. 이번 강의는 측정에 관한 거예요. 측정은 양자와 고전
정보 사이의 인터페이스 역할을 해요. 시스템이 양자 상태에 있을 때 측정이 수행되면,
고전적인 정보가 추출되면서 그 양자 상태에 대한 무언가가 드러나게 되고, 보통 그 상태가 변하거나
과정 중에 파괴되어요. 이 시리즈의 첫 번째 단원에서 다뤘던 양자 정보의 간략한 공식화에서는 보통
사영 측정에 집중했어요. 가장 단순한 유형의 측정인
표준 기저 측정도 포함해서요. 하지만 측정의 개념을 일반화하는 것도 가능한데요,
그게 꽤 유용한 일이에요. 이번 강의에서는 측정을 완전히 일반적인 관점에서 다룰 거예요.
수학적으로 어떻게 표현되는지, 그리고 양자 정보의 일반적인 공식화에 어떻게 들어맞는지도요.
강의 마지막 부분에서는 측정과 연결된 몇 가지 핵심 개념도 살펴볼 거예요. 바로 양자 상태
판별과 양자 상태 단층 촬영이에요. 자, 시작해볼게요. 강의 개요를 먼저 보면요.
늘 그렇듯이 기본부터 시작할 거예요. 측정을 수학적으로 표현하는 두 가지 다르지만
동등한 방법을 포함해서요. 특히 측정을 행렬들의 모음으로 표현할 수 있고,
채널로도 표현할 수 있는데, 이전 강의에서 살짝 언급했었죠. 부분 측정도 다룰 거예요.
다시 말해 더 큰 복합 시스템의 일부에만 수행되는 측정이요.
그 다음에는 Neymark 정리로 넘어갈 거예요. 이건 측정에 관한 근본적인 사실인데요, 기본적으로
일반적인 측정은 항상 Stein spring 표현과 비슷한 방식으로 간단하게 구현할 수 있다는 내용이에요.
요약하면, 일반적인 측정은 항상 먼저 초기화된 작업 공간 시스템을 도입한 다음,
유니터리 연산을 수행하고, 마지막으로 작업 공간 시스템에 표준 기저
측정을 수행하는 방식으로 구현할 수 있어요. 이건 증명하기도 꽤 쉬운데, 어떻게 진행되는지 살펴볼 거예요. 또
이게 이른바 비파괴적 측정과 어떻게 연결되는지도 볼 거예요. 마지막으로 강의 마지막 부분에서는
양자 상태 판별과 양자 상태 단층 촬영에 대해 다룰 거예요. 측정의 수학적
표현부터 시작할게요. 측정은 양자와
고전 정보 사이의 인터페이스를 제공해요. 시스템이 어떤 양자 상태에 있을 때 측정이 수행되면, 고전적인 정보가
그 양자 상태로부터 추출돼요. 게다가 양자 상태는 보통 바뀌거나 경우에 따라서는
완전히 파괴되기도 해요. 처음에는 이른바 파괴적 측정에 집중할 거예요. 여기서는
양자 상태가 들어가고 고전적인 정보만 나오는데, 측정된 시스템의
측정 후 양자 상태에 대한 명세가 없어요. 직관적으로 말하면, 파괴적 측정은
측정된 시스템을 파괴한다고 상상할 수 있어요. 그래서 측정 이후의 상태가
명시되지 않는 거예요. 이게 물리적 장치가 실제로 파괴된다는 뜻은 아니에요. 그냥 수학적인
표현일 뿐이고, 이게 꽤 유용한 표현이에요. 왜냐하면 복잡한 것들을 단순하게 유지하고 핵심적인
수학적 측면에 집중할 수 있게 해주거든요. 파괴적 측정을 표현하는 두 가지 동등한 방법이 있는데,
강의 개요에서 언급했었죠. 파괴적 측정을 표현하는 한 가지 방법은
행렬들의 모음인데요, 특히 각각의 가능한 측정 결과에 대해 하나의 행렬이 있어요.
파괴적 측정을 표현하는 두 번째 방법은 채널인데요, 여기서
입력은 측정되는 시스템의 상태이고, 출력은 항상 대각 밀도 행렬이에요. 이걸
가능한 고전적인 측정 결과들에 대한 확률 분포의 표현으로 해석할 수 있어요.
두 가지 표현은 동등해요. 이게 꽤 유용한데, 주어진 상황에서 더 편리한 표현을 선택할 수 있게 해주기 때문이에요.
비파괴적 측정에 대해서도 다룰 거예요. 여기서는 고전적인 측정 결과 외에도
측정된 시스템의 측정 후 양자 상태도
명시돼요. 비파괴적 측정은 중요하고 자주 등장하지만, 어떤 의미에서는
파괴적 측정만큼 근본적이지는 않아요. 수학적인 관점에서는, 특히 결국
비파괴적 측정은 항상 채널과 파괴적 측정의 합성으로 표현될 수 있어요.
어떻게 그렇게 되는지는 강의 후반부에서 살펴볼게요. 이제 측정, 즉 파괴적
측정이 행렬들의 모음으로 어떻게 표현되는지 살펴볼게요. 이 논의 전반에 걸쳐 X는 측정되는 시스템이라고 할 거예요.
간단하게 하기 위해 몇 가지 가정을 할 거예요. 먼저, X의
고전적인 상태 집합이 어떤 양의 정수 n에 대해 0부터 n-1까지의 정수로 구성된다고 가정할게요. 그리고 측정의 가능한
결과들은 어떤 양의 정수 M에 대해 0부터 M-1까지의 정수예요. 마찬가지로요.
n과 M 사이에 어떤 관계가 있을 필요는 없어요. 둘 다 임의의 양의 정수이고, 물론 이
집합들을 임의의 고전적인 상태 집합으로 대체할 수도 있어요. 먼저 사영
측정이 어떻게 작동하는지 복습해볼게요. 이 시리즈의 세 번째 강의에서 처음 다뤘었죠. 측정 결과가
0부터 n-1까지의 정수라고 가정하면, 사영 측정은 사영들의 모음으로 표현돼요.
Pi 0부터 Pi M-1까지인데, 이들의 합이 항등 행렬이 돼요. 이 행렬들은 모두 X의 고전적인 상태에 대응하는 행과
열을 가져요. 다시 말해 이것들은 모두 n×n
행렬이에요. x가 양자 상태 벡터 s로 표현되는 양자 상태에 있다면, 각각의 가능한 측정
결과 a는 Pi a를 벡터 s에 곱한 것의 유클리드 노름의 제곱과 같은 확률로 나타나요.
어떤 벡터의 유클리드 노름의 제곱은 그 벡터와 자기 자신의 내적과 같아요.
그래서 화면에 표시된 식을 얻게 되고, Pi a가 사영이라는 사실을 이용하면
조금 더 단순화할 수 있어요. 자기 자신에 곱해도 아무 변화가 없거든요.
그리고 마지막으로 순환 성질을 이용해서 얻은 식을 약간 다른 방식으로 다시 쓸 수 있어요.